the entire span of the cell cycle is
divided into two subcategories 90% of
the time is devoted for the interface
which is a preparatory phase and the 10%
of the time is given for the division
phase or the mitotic phase
among these mitotic phase the shortest
ones are the metaphase and
anaphase so in this video we'll talk
about the events that are taking place
in metaphase and anaphase now looking to
the microscope we see a live movie where
the chromosomes are segregated in the
metaphasic plate and are separated and
going to the two separate poles and the
end of prophase what happens is all the
nuclear membrane is broken down the
chromosomes are condensed and totally
packaged now there are spindles which
has grown which are growing and
shrinking trying to capture microtubules
this growing and shrinking microtubules
would eventually capture chromosome at
its kinetic or now kinda tackle is a
specialized region at the chromosome if
we look at the structure of the tiny
kinda coal we would see an outer fibrous
layer there is an inner kinetochore and
there is an outer kinetochore and the
microtubule talks to the outer tinier to
quran' it gets attracted by the outer
fibrous layer
I know tuber is different from the other
regions of the chromosome because it has
a histone variant and its nucleus emits
no net cenp-a
now sale has to ensure that during the
creation the chromosomes are equally
segregated and moving towards two poles
that means cell has to understand the
tension is proper from both the sides
and it is proper time to pull them apart
but if the tension is unequal from both
the sides
what happened there could be a uneven
segregation of the chromosome as a
result what's shown here
two of these chromatids are going in one
side and other of the other side is
receiving nothing
this might really result in chromosomal
aberration now let us look at how really
these chromosomes are separated during
anaphase or at the end of the metaphase
there are enzymes which are known as
separators which can actually break down
the cohesin rings no coherent rings as
the name suggests they really worried
the chromatids in a cohesive fashion but
separators cannot work individually
because it is already inhibited by
securing factors like MPF and enough
which promoting complex breaks down
securing as a result separase would be
free and now the separates can really
break the cohesin rings once the cohesin
rings are broken now it is proper time
to pull those chromosomes apart because
there is nothing holding them back but
let's say there is a situation where
there is a unequal tension that is
detected by the tension sensing
mechanism such as mad - man - is a
kinase and it inhibits the MPF and the
APC and as a result MP an MPF an APC can
not activate separase and further it
cannot break down the cohesin rings so
the chromatids stay attached to each
other this situation would give the cell
some more time to rectify itself and it
would prevent chromosomal aberrations
that's how stringent it is this is also
known as spindle assembly checkpoint by
the way now when everything is proper
the cells the chromosomes are actually
aligned in the metaphase plate and the
tension is equal from both the sides now
it is time to pull them apart in the
both side and if the segregation is
proper at the end of anaphase both the
poles would receive equal amount of
genetic material and nuclear formation
would start in the telophase so I hope
this video was informative if you like
like this video the video a thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you